como si se tratara de una guerra civil
una línea de policías fue acercándose
lentamente decenas de personas los
esperaban con escudos de plástico
piedras y palos cerca de 4.000 agentes
fueron movilizados para vaciar este
terreno baldío que se había convertido
en el hogar de 1200 familias se acercó
un policía me dijo que no teníamos que
retirar yo le dije que quería sacar mis
cosas y me dijo que mañana iba a poder
venir a salvar mi cosa entonces le pedí
por favor que me dejara sacar leche
pañales y dinero un poco de ropa para
mis hijos y me fui la llegada del joven
19 argentinas agudizó una recesión
establecida en el país desde 2018 en
total cerca de 3000 personas se
asentaron en este campo y luego de
dialogar con el gobierno provincial
algunos partieron voluntariamente pero
aún quedaban cerca de 200 el gobierno ha
prometido subsidios de hasta 600 dólares
mensuales durante seis meses y refugios
temporales pero esto no bastó para
convencerlos a todos de partir
al mismo tiempo en la capital argentina
miembros de partidos de izquierda y
activistas marcharon en contra del
desalojo es decir acá hay un repudio muy
grande y es un repudio que se va a
profundizar porque acá se tiene que
resolver no solo el problema de la
familia que ahora están en la calle sino
también del resto de la calle que no
encontró quizás un canal para expresar
esa desesperación de no poder ciudad a
fin de mes no tener un techo donde
dormir en el primer trimestre del año la
tasa de desempleo en argentina fue del
10,4 por ciento según las proyecciones
de la consultora ecolatina la tasa para
el segundo trimestre habría subido al 14
por ciento